i've gotten a chance to spend the day at
deep mine and talk to demus habess his
big dream is to apply ai
to the questions of science certainly to
the questions of physics have you gotten
a chance to interact with him well i
know quite well i've uh
he's one of my heroes certainly
and i remember i'm sure he would say
this and i remember the first time i met
him he said that he was like me he wants
to understand the universe
but he thought the best thing to do was
to try and develop ai and then with the
help of ai he'd stand more chance of
understanding the universe yeah and i
think he's right about that so and of
course uh um
although we're
familiar with the way his uh computers
play go and uh chess um
he's already made contributions to
science through
uh understanding protein folding better
than the best human chemists and so
already he's on the path to showing ways
in which computers have the power to
learn and do things by having a bit to
analyze enormous samples in a short time
uh to do better than humans and so um i
think he would resonate with what i've
just said that it may be that
in these other fundamental questions the
computers will play a crucial role
yeah and they're also doing quantum
mechanical simulation of electrons
they're doing
control of
high temperature plasma fusion reactors
yes that's a new thing which is very
interesting they can suppress the
instabilities in these tokamaks
better than any other way
you